foreign
we want to establish an amazing masjid
for the sake of allah in the country of
norway click on the link and donate now
for the sake of allah
brothers and sisters and dear friends so
will smith decides to go and slap chris
rock in the face why did he deserve it
or was it just a mere joke let's watch
for ourselves and decide
i'm out here oh
richard
oh wow
wow dude
yeah it was a g.i james keep my wife's
name out
i'm going to okay
so i could oh okay
so guys you saw that for yourself now
when i watched that clip myself when i
saw him going to the stage these people
are actors so you know sometimes they do
this prank on each other or they just
stage the whole thing so him walking the
way smith was walking didn't look real
to me the snap that he did didn't look
real to me i thought it was all just
like you know here we go another stage
um thing but when he sat down
and when i look at look at chris rock's
face and when i saw how he was like
don't you ever
effing talk about my wife and i thought
nah that's that's that's not a joke that
looks serious but the question that
needs to be asked is why did he do it
brother and sisters the relationship
that he has with his wife is not really
something that anyone would want to be
in he seems that he's deeply in love so
much so that we believe in islam that
anyone that has that kind of love to
such a level that is deserving that
allah should be having that love allah
will humiliate you with the very thing
that you put before him and i feel as if
with will smith that's exactly what's
happening his wife went and can we see
cheated oh no they had a breakup or he
helped her wanted to you know have a
relationship with this other individual
and he just allowed it this is this is
someone where we call and you know in
english terms called the [ __ ]
someone does it the youth someone that
has no
protective jealousy of his woman folk
and now all of a sudden he turns a blind
eye to all of that and chris rock makes
a joke yes maybe it should not because
he the joke he's making about is about
his wife having this illness where she
has to shave her head and it seems like
from the video that we watched which you
can see on my left or right hand side
that will smith was actually laughing at
the joke so what happened
what we know and what i've been told is
that he looked at his wife and he saw
that she was really upset and that hurt
him so he got up and went and snapped
the guy in his face
now
rightly so if somebody insults my wife
i would be an absolute whatever you want
to call me to be standing there and
laughing this is what happens bro and
sisters where we learn a couple of
things number one making jokes okay
where's the freedom of speech gone where
is it oh it was just a joke no people's
emotions get hurt so this notion this
false notion of freedom of speech you
can see people when somebody's really
dear to them
that you get hurt but if it was us
muslims if it was a muslim man that
happened to wallahi everyone be like it
was just a joke you couldn't take it no
when it's will smith some people justify
it whatever it may be this is the
hypocrisy and the double standards and
the prophet peace be upon him is the
hadith of the prophet peace be upon him
where he was talking about a man one of
the companions who said if i saw my wife
in bed with another man he will
basically get the end of my sword and
the prophet peace be upon him said you
think this man has ghirar indeed allah's
gira is greater than his gera
to his wife
this is the protective jealousy islam
has given so much so that subhanallah
maybe it might be that the real reason
is that will smith because he hasn't
been acting like a man and let's be
honest a woman likes a real man if you
if a woman is married to a man where
some guy's coming and chirps in and
talking to in a flirty way and he
doesn't do nothing about it oh i love
you still it's not a woman's nature to
stick by such a man i'll be honest with
you if you're such a man who could allow
your wife to go with another man and god
knows do what don't be surprised when
you come home and find another man in
your bed you should slap yourself that
is why i handle understand we have
protective jealousy towards our woman
folk we're not the type to like hey you
know look at my why you know in a mini
dress you know check her out you know
your eye candy no this is why
alhamdulillah allah has taught us which
is in our fitrah to have protective
jealousy of our woman folk and this is
why i believe at that moment will smith
and i'll end on this
this is the reason why he felt as if he
had to prove a point because he probably
looked and thought you know what i
turned the blind eye to so many things
you know and now if i turn the blind eye
to this you know his wife is going to
think you know what kind of a man are
you you know i've went beside you know
not behind your back what i've told you
and when was another man
someone was taking sexual intimacy you
know and you accept that woman back well
i would rather
i don't want to talk big anyway but i
wouldn't be like
and then on top of that he probably
looked up for you know what for once in
my life i need to have some
i need to do something about it and even
after he slapped him it seemed like his
wife was disappointed so it looks like
she's not going to be happy regardless
and i'll end on that no brother and
sister there's nothing else in which
needs to be said alhamdulillah for islam
that we have this
protective jealousy for our wife and a
woman folk and it's a beautiful thing
and guess what every single man has it
it's about at what moment at what time
is it going to shine and maybe for will
smith it was at this moment
may allah keep us firm till next time
assalamu alaikum
do you agree with me do you disagree
with me put in the comment section below
assalamu alaikum